disclaimer dieses video beinhaltet
spinnen schlangen erbrochenes und leider
auch menschliches blut ihr findet dazu
an den entsprechenden stellen
rechtzeitig am unteren bildschirmrand
eine trigger warnung samt zeitstempel
damit ihr die stellen überspringen oder
wegschauen könnt solltet ihr empfindlich
auf diese dinge reagieren hat sich euch
diesen disclaimer dringend ernst zu
nehmen
willkommen im amazonas ich wurde von der
naturschutzorganisation wilderness
international eingeladen die letzten
noch vollständig intakten ökosystemen
dieser erde mit eigenen augen zu sehen
das ist der zweite und letzte teil der
serie indem ich in wenigen augenblicken
für 24 stunden mutterseelenallein im
regenwald ausgesetzt werde eine
hängematte schutzplane schlafsack
nahrung oder wasser wenn ich nicht am
boden mit den insekten und spinnen
schlafen möchte muss ich mir selbst ein
bett bauen und wenn ich essen oder bei
tropischer hitze lebenswichtiges wasser
trinken will muss ich es in der wildnis
suchen ohne geld und auch gefilmt ohne
kameramann und das ist bisher im ersten
teil passiert
ist einfach an jeder ecke irgendwas
total cool ist
musst du es
nicht gut darin zu schlafen weil sich
daraus wieder zu erhöhen
aghasadeh musil oder kameras am tag vor
der kamera
wenn ich denn jetzt nicht so im coolen
warum finden ideen wie kann ich denn
sonst irgendwie wir haben hinter dem
baum
ist nicht so schlimm wie man denkt ich
weiß nicht was ich glaube es ist nicht
so schlimm aus wenn ich nicht das ist
was allerdings noch viel wichtiger sein
wird als essen zu finden ist sauberes
trinkwasser vor das als opa friedrich
will oder ist das irgendwie auch einen
gewissen mengen giftig wenn ich darf
mich nicht mit einer pflanze zu
vergiften bleibt aber noch 1 offen was
alles gibt es da draußen das mich essen
beißen vergiften oder stecken könnte
ausgehend von dem was ich von meinen
geist kiki und chris gelernt habe
entsteht also nun meine packliste für
den regen kategorie 1 filme damit ich
meine erfahrung da draußen dokumentieren
kann nämlich mehrere kameras mikrofone
eine menge ersatz akkus und eine
kopflampe mit damit ich auch nachts
filmen kann und ihr seht wie sehr ich
mich in die hosen macht zweite kategorie
sicherheit bestehend aus erster hilfe
fit sowie desinfektionsspray und co
zudem ein funktelefon und gps gerät um
im absoluten notfall hilfe zu rufen
helau christa chemie
ich habe mir lange überlegt das nicht
mitzunehmen und ich möchte die 24
stunden auch schaffen ohne diese
notfallausrüstung wurde aber
eindringlich gesagt raus zu gehen ohne
notfall gps ist für mich war sie der
sichere tod wirklich bei mir führen um
da draußen zurecht zu kommen werde ich
ein taschenmesser einen feuerstrahl ein
dünnes mücken netz und eine machete
aber ein teil der vorbereitung habe ich
bisher noch verschwiegen ein teil der
passierte werden chicchi mir beigebracht
hat wie man im dschungel ein eigenes
bett baut ein teil der noch mal alles
verändern sollte ein teil der den
aufmerksam unter euch bereits im ersten
teil aufgefallen ist wieso ist jetzt ein
fehler alles schon wieder verletzt was
du wieder los thomas loos ich war also
wieder mit tiki im dschungel wir haben
ein video gedreht für meinen
zweikanalton riehl indem ich von ihm
lernen wie man im dschungel ein eigenes
bett baut
our
watch it
als er
a
ist ein bisschen schwindelig
wir uns gehalten ich wollte
[Musik]
ich habe gesagt dass das gefährlich sind
und bin ich eine offene wunde mitten im
dschungel da war doch was ich durchsuche
meine drei im presto händeringend auf
der suche nach einer tetanus impfung
extra für diese weise habe ich mich doch
gegen alles impfen lassen einmal gelb
über 3 x gold 1 x silber 1 x usb 2 marco
lover einmal typhus einmal meningitis
aber wo ist diese verdammte tätern und
stempel ich finde kein
[Musik]
bild run noch
gedanklich war das experiment für mich
an diesem punkt bereits vorbei alleine
im dschungel mit einer unbrauchbaren
hand die jederzeit entzünden könnte
absolut um während ich das skript für
dieses video schreibe wünschte ich mir
ich könnte hier einen guten grund
einfügen der mich dazu bewogen hat aber
stattdessen schneiden wir mit den worten
vergibt ich bin gekommen um regenwald zu
schützen unkreativ auf eine szene in der
ich einen haftungsausschluss
unterschreiben in dem klargestellt wird
dass ich mir da gefahren des 24 stunden
dunkel experiments bewusst bin und
dadurch niemand verklagt werden kann
[Musik]
hey siri stelle an den wecker in 24
stunden
das handy kommt jetzt nicht mehr benutzt
und leben mit dem wecker luxus dass ich
mal meine uhr braucht um zu wissen
meinen rhythmus und konnte das zeigt wie
viel zu verlieren und jetzt muss ich
auch dass ich wenn ich mich mit der
machete auch
wieso nicht da reinkommen
[Musik]
man kann schwer voran unterheben dieser
blätter können fährt ich spinne lauern
hier drücken sie jetzt ganz begebe aus
ich werde jetzt hier auf den meisten
benutzten um die ganzen
vielleicht ein bisschen zur seite zu
drücken wenn ihr euch jetzt erhofft habe
dass ich hier durchgehend allem war
alles kaputt
so muss ich leider ein bisschen
enttäuschend
also ich kann sie kann natürlich über
hier durchgehend aber
unter jedem dieser dinger könnte wickeln
der spinne daran setzen oder eine raupe
ok oder ein crosstrainer kefer laut den
experten die wir über wohl des
international kennengelernt haben
handelt es sich hierbei wohl um einen
blauen rüsselkäfer aber das war selbst
für die expertin weil diese qualität bei
weitem nicht leicht zu entziffern da ist
im amazonas mehr als eine million
verschiedene insekten gibt auf der
wikipedia seite von blauen rüsselkäfer
sieht man auch dass es selbst hier
dutzende verschiedenen gibt es mit
unterschiedlichen maserungen diese
artenvielfalt zieht sich natürlich
durchs komplette tierreich säugetiere
wie das capybara einem riesigen
meerschweinchen das gerne schwimmt aber
auch quasi mit uns verwandte primaten
finden hier ein zuhause und mehr als
genug essen damit das so bleibt
wilderness international auch zusammen
mit unserer hilfe regenwald grundstücke
auf und schützt sie vor der abholung
alleine wir als community haben mit dem
ersten teil der vor wenigen tagen
erschienen ist bereits über 35.000
quadratmeter geschützt und ich vermute
dass das mit diesem video nochmal
deutlich mehr wert der link dazu mit dem
ihr jetzt pro einem euro einen
quadratmeter regenwald unsterblich
machen könnt ist in der beschreibung
freunde sagen was fehlt ist ein baum
oder gefallen
ach du scheiße sind früchte oben die
sind schön runter gefallen aber ich
würde auch nicht auf dem kopf
ich muss jetzt langsam mal ein gutes
wort kommen
[Musik]
also ich muss ehrlich gestehen der
superschwere jeglichen drang zu
widerstehen einfach alles mit der
machete kurz und klein zu hauen einfach
damit ich hier einen weg habe
wo ich nicht angst haben muss und
irgendwas giftiges run zu laufen ich hab
hier so'n bambus den gefunden er hier
ist definitiv nicht mehr geil
der supermarkt aber er hier den ich
gerade
gefällt ob der hat was da drin haben wir
schon ein stück her so abgeschnitten und
da kommt was hab ich habe super schießt
also ich keine ahnung ob ich also
keine ahnung ich das trinken sollte ich
also ich habe gesagt ich kann's trinken
zwar muss aber er ist
feinschmecker war aber noch nicht mal
guter schluck aber was besser ist finde
ich nicht achten
man kann jetzt auch sowie bei muss mit
wie ich kann hier ist auch noch was sehr
sehr geil sehr sehr geil dass ich nicht
das muss
das ist krass
1 2 3 und 4 karte klingelt
da ist was ich häufig herausgesprudelt
mannschaft dass ein loch hat hätte der
ball muss ein loch oder wer gerissen
dann dürfte ich das wasser das er in
seinen kann man speichert auf keinen
fall trinken weil es dann mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit verunreinigt wäre und
ich habe wirklich wenig lust mehr den
einen oder anderen parasiten anzufangen
nach bambus und es wird sich bis zu
scharf
[Musik]
jung als er es dann richtig dicker ast
oder gefallen direkt neben mir
wir sind ganz schön dicke bambus aber
ich habe angst dass das runterkommen
eine hängen als super viele sachen
einfach lose drin
das heißt ich hätte da mal reinhauen
hoffen dass herunterfällt stück
zurückgehen
während das ganze zeug da oben
herunterfallen kann und ich krieg
hoffentlich dann keinen kopf
der kamerad richtig viel was da unten
raus auch also der is jut ach du scheiße
ich bin ein dschungel
und erheben
ich konnte also ich kann wirklich nicht
drauf kann sich alleine kommt bin ich
kann mich nicht mal hinsetzen und sicher
sein weil man ständig mit diesem foto
oben und erfüllen
irgendwas gegen die kleinen viecher mich
an krabbeln
gut ist muss irgendwo ankommen was ohne
dass nicht irgendein master haut ich
ziehe gerade in zehn meter langen bambus
ding mitten im dschungel
okay das ist die dümmste idee die ich
jemals hatte ab
wann platzt ich kann sich ganz abreißen
sonst kommt der baum glaub ich glaub ich
mach das beste draus wenn ich hier
abhauen
ich habe gerade ein liter wasser
ausgeschüttet
gar nicht gut
hass drin
und da ist ein riesen schlug drin als ob
er so viel wasser drin ist
[Applaus]
pauli
schädigt sie viel wasser mit ein
bisschen zitronengras wie sie im
dschungel als verbunden ist herr
integration todes hingehauen nicht
durchkamen und wenn ich daran wackel
dackel
jahren gehen bis zum baum und dann fällt
vielleicht irgend lockerer manier und
auf meinen kopf
[Musik]
einfach faszinierend
es waren auch immer ich weiß nicht diese
nacht vor ewigkeiten richtig fetter baum
umgefallen und entwurzelt und na ja also
ich bin froh dass ich nicht dieses was
rum trinken muss sondern dass ich das
enorme karte hier bambus zu finden ich
würde schätzen gerade in den blicken der
sind gesamt locker in littering sogar am
schlafplatz aber hier ist es ganz so
nass
werde ich mit sicherheit nicht schlafen
muss irgend einem wald in den rhein wo
es ein bisschen höher gelegen ist und
nicht das komplette wasser gesammelt
wobei man auch sagen muss dass es was
ich echt sehr sehr klar aussieht aber
nicht ganz so klar wie man beim gehen
auf der suche nach einem schlafplatz
finde ich einen der wahrscheinlich
tausende pilzarten dieses hier im
amazonas gibbs den ich ausnahmsweise
eindeutig identifizieren kann während
eines trainings hat mir der gute chicken
nämlich gezeigt dass man den saft dieses
pilzes als ort tropfen verwenden kann
wenn man ohrenschmerzen hat so ich habe
jetzt schlafplatz gefunden und mit
ziemlich gut sieht so aus
ist das tun und da geht mir gut weil wir
haben ja diesen schrägen baum der lebt
noch den jetzt richtig gut
und das dadurch richtig stabil und wird
nicht umkippen mit nun acht mich aber
trotzdem vor herabfallenden ästen
schützen dies hier andauernd gepflegt
alles am boden voll mit dicken ästen die
einfach 40 meter herunter gefallen sind
von den ganz hohen bäume um und das ding
könnte mir das leben retten und darf
nicht vergessen
hört ihr das die kassen geräusche man
aber nicht vergessen dass das hier ein
termin ist und die termiten können die
theoretisch essen oder sind
das glaube ich nicht weil die westen ist
das eigentlich mit nässe sind rund
arbeit sind bestimmt irgendwie
67 meter in der luft verträgen werde ich
nicht erreichen können aber ich war mir
das mannschaft hat das wir geil dass die
gelder schlacht rizzo mein gott und
abwasser und java richtig durst habe
richtig durch jetzt nicht aufgehoben
hat super viele leckere früchte gefunden
die ich mir als wir später einsammeln
wäre dafür ein ziemlich sicher dass die
früchte sind die mir zig gezeigt hat und
die auch erst kann und die sind super
lecker einfach krass also ich bin hier
einfach ein genie wann ich habe wasser
gefunden ich habe essen gefunden haben
ich glaube keine ahnung ich für zwei
drei stunden
die inhalteanbieter urwaldbewohner
gegessen
was ist das
[Musik]
vor lauter gier habe ich eine frucht
nach der anderen eingesammelt und wurde
vom dschungel ähnlich wie hänsel und
gretel von der hexe weggelockt von einem
perfekten schlafplatz nachdem ich so
lange gesucht haben ich stehe irgendwo
im urwald und schaue mich um doch ich
finde nicht mehr zurück die suche
beginnt also von vorne
[Musik]
herausgefunden habe ich nicht zufällig
gewählt ich habe hier nämlich zwei gaben
zwei bäume die aktien und eine gabelung
haben das sind zwei bäume weniger die
ich selber irgendwie abhaken muss und
hinstellen muss man dann kann ich ja
quasi einen langen hals trüber sparen
der mich dann vor herabfallenden sachen
schützen würde weil da habe ich gesagt
am allermeisten angst und zusätzlich ist
es ja auch nicht ganz so dicht besiedelt
das heißt hier gibt es nicht so viele
bäume an der stelle gibt so viele büsche
und währungspolitik anja relativ gut
einfach umgehen das ist für mich super
geil ist weil ich hier ein bisschen
weniger angst hat und mir zu sagen ja
und zweitens minimiere ich die anteil
der este und krise die ich jetzt hier
anpacken muss
aber das extrem dumm ich habe den bau
mal geschüttelt und jedes insekt das
drin gewesen so über mich drüber
geflogen ach du scheiße die vorstellung
dass dann eine vorgespannte kann ist
nicht unbedingt die angenehmste ich
werde auf jeden fall
bald mal mich group aus den und an mal
durchschütteln lassen sich gegen eine
spinnerin sich versteckt so der kollege
hier ist schon tot ich muss jetzt noch
wegschaffen irgendwie
[Musik]
sehr wahrscheinlich einer von den resten
dies heute nacht hier runter gehauen hat
was das da laufen wir herum das ist auch
kein vogel der seelsorge tätig jetzt
fragen sollen wie sich ein jahr gehört
ich bin im kopf irgendwie also wir
sowieso schwierig weil ja alle zugleich
aussieht und ich hatte sagt wir kommen
also ich
meine welt bauen weil die zeit anbricht
weil die nacht anbricht
aber ich habe auch ein paar gar keine
motivation ebenfalls zu machen also ich
kann damit die dringlichkeit nicht
richtig bewusst kommen die nicht mit
fragen wie bin ich gerade so ziemlich
gleichgültig irgendwie
und ich habe gerade überhaupt kein
richtiges gefühl
für mich selbst so
komisch
naja was jetzt kommt ist so probiert
aber das haben wie gesagt das war
wirklich machen und zwar einmal um sein
tempo um pinkeln
damit die tiere wissen ja okay gut da
ist wer
es ist was ist jetzt
[Musik]
haha ich jetzt ein bisschen aus erstens
weil wir gerade sauber ist und sein kann
als das zeug das ich jetzt hier wirklich
komplett voll geschützt hat das kann
einmal trocken ja ich glaube dass noch
ganz gut
[Musik]
da ist jetzt übrigens mein comment ich
mache alle sachen aktuell immer super
langsam und behäbig und ich vergesse
weil eigentlich immer was ich tun wollte
das ist echt krass also ich will das
kann man gucken und zusammenbauen und
habe ich grade mal von ameisen ablenken
lassen die einfach nur am boden krabbelt
ist perfekt jetzt brauche ich im bett so
hatte ich sozusagen wenig verbraucht 4
erst an einer gabelung die werden hier
den boden angebote nur angesteckt wie
dazu gebuddelt dann zwei stabile erste
die ich darüber legt und dann nach
längerer ist die ungefähr so lang sind
wie ich die dann das bett gehen er ist
verrückt
es ist wirklich verrückt also ich muss
im kopf zusammen reißen damit ich
überhaupt weiß was ich machen will jetzt
kommt raus und ich weiß auch nicht wieso
also ich hab eigentlich jetzt genug
wasser getrunken
ich bin noch nicht so lange draußen
aber es geht einfach alles gleich aus
das kind sofort um ich will die kamera
nicht ausmachen wenn die kamera aus ich
fühle mich alleine
es ist wirklich dumm wenn die kamera aus
ist gegen mich trotzdem noch mit mir
selber aber dann komme ich mir irgendwie
dann bin ich nicht ganz überzeugt dass
ich nicht auch für rückblick hatte
wirklich aber wenn ich mit der kamera
das ist für mich ja noch mal und noch
mal krass also man kann hier wirklich
einfach nicht leider nicht weiter als
zehn meter schauen
das ist gerade
das nicht geht
[Musik]
vor ort
ist abgefahren
gefragt war
[Musik]
warstein gerade
die raubkatze retten
[Musik]
h
und schmeckt gut
[Musik]
ich hätte niemals gedacht dass ich das
mal tun wird arbeiten jetzt ein schönes
blatt aus und eine beschreibung zufolge
sollte das glas einfach nicht hält sich
sein sondern fest und das ist es das gut
das ist eine spinne drin wie in hall
strecke
zwei blätter uns jetzt passiert können
wir vielleicht denken
ich werde berichten
ja das war es wahrlich nicht so geil wie
ich es mir vorgestellt hat und ich hab
schon echt nicht gerne vorgestellt oh
mein gott sagen wir jetzt noch ein paar
für heute nacht weil kein bock dann
gegen mitternacht ein paar blätter
sammeln zu müssen ich hätte nie gedacht
dass ich
mein klub wir sammeln muss ja
es ist was es ist kein baum gefunden der
sieht recht schnell wieder und er ist
vom sturm umgefallen ich weiß nich waren
die drei frisch aus und er eigentlich
ganz gut für über mein bett was schutz
quasi vor herabfallenden ästen und
deswegen hat man auch die passende länge
bringen
wo es anstrengend und
der muss ungefähr
drei minuten lang sein aber lieber zu
kurz machen wir lieber mal so gut gerade
halb
[Musik]
so sei eine gute kür zu gelangen
aber ich glaube ich sparen lieber
energie soll jetzt auch schon relativ
tief ich meine sie spät ist ich werde
bald dunkler werden ich habe nicht
wirklich tief in mein bett und ich bin
jetzt schon so ultra fertig also es ist
so krass auch mental so krass
ich habe nochmal im baum gefunden denen
der strom umgehauen hat oder hat sogar
zwei
aber der schon super mensch der wirklich
nicht mehr tragen aber der hier
da sind noch stabil aus
ja also jetzt nicht so verschaltet
verstummen die bäume abgehauen hat aber
ja ich freue mich dass nicht mal machen
und dass ich den kollegen gerne nutzen
kann
diese tiere klingen wie ein dinosaurier
ich weiß nicht was bringen die forscher
halten soll
aber die tiere von denen diese berufe
kommen denken sich wohl genau dasselbe
und fragen sich was der aktuelle unten
zu treiben aber wie sich später
herausstellt hat sich der vogel nicht
von mir gestört gefühlt sondern von
einem artgenossen mit dem es später
sogar noch richtig ans eingemachte ging
ich habe das bett
ich wollte mich hoffentlich besser war
mir geht recht nicht gerade ein bisschen
hügel
im sambódromo
rolf menzel orientation lost thing die
konserven lux bisher noch lust
angebot gut
ich höre immer wieder geräusche von
tieren die mir angst machen mein guide
tig ii hat mit dem neuen fall
beigebracht krachte machen
[Musik]
elia
[Applaus]
[Musik]
alter wird so schwindelig gerade ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt
menzels bambus wasser ist doch nicht so
sauber betrag sei nicht so gut oder er
geständig war
also immer gleich aussieht ich verbringe
mehr zeit damit mich zusammenzureißen
und nicht irgendwie abzudrehen als hier
im bett fertig zu bauen und jetzt wird
gleich dunkel
also
ich habe nicht so richtig also ich weiß
nicht ich bin nicht weiter freund
während anzurufen
und zu sagen hey du mich ab
b
ich will mich hinlegen meine augen
schließen und zu mir kommen ich brauche
sicherheit und halt wenn ich es nur
schaffen würde endlich mein bett fertig
zu bauen könnte ich mich ausruhen und
mich sammeln der schwindel würde sich
schlagartig besser mit meiner
allerletzten kraft habe ich die aufgabe
lungen in den weichen boden
[Musik]
man muss
muss
durch
[Musik]
okay das war
jetzt ein christkind
can you hear
me go fresh murdoch
[Musik]
sechs stunden
ich glaube es hat ungefähr fünf stunden
gebraucht und während dahinten wir also
jeglicher art zoffen habe ich ganz
schnell realisiert dass ich glaube ich
so eine erfahrung nicht braucht also auf
gar keinen fall alleine und auf gar
keinen fall nochmal und die im dschungel
schon gar nicht
[Musik]
da sind wirklich richtig sitzt
aber ja
[Musik]
etf
also ich fand dass er vorher super also
der krasse erfahrung aber vielleicht war
das auch was man machen muss um das zu
realisieren aber dschungel ist geil
richtig geil aber alleine und ohne
ahnung
[Musik]
wir müssen uns ja auch dass durch das
übelste im unterholz schlagen um
überhaupt zu kurz zu kommen also das ist
echt
ganz so einfach
waren thomas ist da habe ich mir erst
mal den dicksten dorn in den finger rein
gehauen
[Musik]
am meer
aber sie
haben hier
[Musik]
außerdem
drohte er
dies ist
ein klares
verfahren neu aufrollen trikot und chili
hot from the storm ist
und beim welser polizei eine moderne
[Gelächter]
und
schick ich weiß gar nicht was es war ich
weiß ja nicht ob es jetzt das ob es
jetzt das mangelware waren halt nur fünf
stunden kann die seit heute vor richtig
wie die wasser gezogen und die recht
schnell
ja und da so bold halten ich wirklich
war aber ich habe auch gut geschwitzt
habe meine sachen aufgehangen ich habe
ich versucht es mal zu sein sogar
rucksack nicht mal am boden gelassen und
am ring an dem er keine tür gegangen
also hatte richtig glücklich hat einmal
bahnhofs gefunden wollte viel wasser
drin ist muss ich auch mal sehen dass
des todes wie wasser also ich denke das
will ich daran dass ich ein bisschen
krank wurde weil ja leistung gleich
ausziehen wenn ich mich zu drehen und
dann habe ich nicht wirklich merken wo
ich gerade war und dann schaue ich nach
oben und dann bin ich irgendwann das
also habe ich mich schon was getrunken
weil ich mal überwand dachten okay
musste schon ein bisschen mehr trinken
haben wir einen schluck ausgetrunken und
das hat auch hart nachbar musste
schmeckt also das war wirklich es hat
super geschmeckt und daran hat sich auch
nicht so lange dauern dass ich habe
davor schon gut was gemerkt aber danach
war es dann wirklich recht schnell und
einfach draußen
altrip
so sei
ein jude der action-reihe
headcoaches kontrollen self right here
and more time
weniger grip und reality denn hektische
building desktop habe ich die ganze zeit
irgendwie jetzt heute zu sein
und damit andere zu quatschen
[Musik]
die reiseleiter
man kann sie überhaupt nicht vorstellen
wie es ist den wald zu sitzen bis man es
selbst erlebt wird sich wahrscheinlich
ausgemalt wie sein wird nur der
romantisch regenwald nicht geil ist ja
auch aber die eigentliche erfahrung ist
dann das ganz anderes ich dachte
natürlich dass sie angst hat aber das
ist ja so übel weil es geht
und ich habe so schnell wirklich ich
kann sagen aber mein verstand verlieren
das hätte ich geglaubt nicht kommen
sehen
der dschungel hat mich gefressen und
mich nach fünf stunden gnadenlos wieder
ausgespuckt und ich habe zurückgestuft
[Musik]
ich bin gesund ich war noch drei tage
lang komplett außer gefecht habe ich
unzählige mal übergeben aber ich bin
gesund ich habe kein leeres ich habe
keine parasiten ich habe es echt
ziemlich coole standen gut mein finger
wenn ihr sehen wollen wie meinen finger
unter dem verband von nahem ausgesehen
hat habe ich euch auf installieren keine
bildstrecke vom heilungsprozess gepostet
aber noch viel wichtiger ist natürlich
der heilungsprozess vom regenwald diese
woche im büro hat sehr viel verändert
und ich will mich bei williams
international dafür bedanken dass sie
uns gezeigt haben dass die welt eben
nicht komplett hoffnungslos verloren ist
sondern dass man tatsächlich etwas
dagegen tun kann die vernichtung des
regenwaldes geht echt unfassbarer
sandmann kann sich das wirklich einfach
nicht vorstellen normal sind
langfristige ansätze und lösungen immer
die besten manche sachen kann man
einfach nicht von heute auf morgen
machen man muss einmal 20 jahre im
voraus plant das problem ist der
regenwald hat wahrscheinlich keine 20
jahre mehr indem er einfach auch wegen
der lösung will das international
handelt genau jetzt das team bestehen
aus dem vorstand und vielen weiteren
tollen menschen zu denen auch logos
gehören wieder ticket kaufen
regenwaldflächen einfach auf und zwar
bevor es andere machen können er ist ein
ziemlich simple idee und komplett genial
finanziert wird das ganze von leuten wir
euch die mit ihrer teilhabe zeigen dass
ihnen der regenwald gesund mehr wert ist
als kaputt mit teil eins von diesem
video haben wir bereits über 35.000 wir
haben wir den regenwald geschützt was
komplett riesig ist wir können jetzt
über den linken der beschreibung dazu
beitragen als unser community wald noch
viel größer wird vielen dank für alle
die daran teilnehmen haben die truppe um
julian es international echt gut
kennengelernt und auch richtig party
gemacht und zusammen richtig viel geilen
meisten spaß gemacht und ich glaube auch
nicht das ist das letzte mal war
[Musik]